welcome to this video playing donk donk
from the US I don't know maybe a polka
reference let's see how it's playing oh
you gotta close Sicilian quickly is
playing quickly this is quite apparent
so i probably can't castle should I go
with 'if I've in this position or I can
also go with Ruby aid now be five this e
five so I must avoid that
yeah as usual whatever you can say a
bottom is not playing slowly every move
is coming like headed on the board for a
million times could be true i mean to
close the Cillian um maybe get rather
often if you if you play one day for i'd
have this in your repertoire okay um I
go e six you might have f6 up this is
not really very nice I would then have
kinguggi I probably should try to gain
some space here that's not ideal
i'm giving up d 5 i know i want to take
i can take with the pawn actually this
is stupid you can take with the pond and
i only thought about Knight takes Knight
takes Knight takes f6 but you can take
also with the pawn Wow oh that's a
really bad position
my main hope is that he is not thinking
at all so he will definitely make some
mistakes but position is so is tricky
very very tricky and 93 s not scaring me
so much just play it play it solid and
what what are you doing here but what do
you think I don't know this is not a bad
game okay your black ass I'm just
winning here only need to avoid our
immediate blunders let's see Queen 2 2
h8 maybe h8 h 6
I don't blunder piece or anything I'm
fine very fine
and always taking time
97 s the next next step here must get
the Knight to f4 if possible check check
that's a route white forfeits due to
disconnection I don't I don't get those
games I'm sorry he first dashes out all
moves and I'm totally totally busted
only needs to rest a little bit of
effort to put me away and then I can
hope yeah I played thoroughly played
this terribly I mean yeah I'm under huge
pressure the computers interestingly
enough not not much it's not very
impressed here just given it as equal
and maybe this was bad I don't know I
wanted to take here on d5 I was thinking
this this should be fairly solid still
maybe it isn't better a thought but then
he can he can play this and now I must
go to a very bad square night a5 looks
looks terrible and he's got the suit
pressure anyway this I'm not sure about
but it should should keep some advantage
I took yeah he takes is very interesting
but he played this instantly should be
six and 93 Brooke f1 is much more
interesting putting more pressure on f6
I probably must take something like this
okay cylinder under much pressure
it's not good food like I'm just I'm
just worse but this was another instant
move yeah it looks like I should defend
I think but he played h4 h5 Jim here I
don't know I'm just you just don't gave
me this point for no particular reason
it's not winning or anything but clearly
blackest is better now yeah he can
certainly defend better word okay i mean
i'm not sure what his game plan is it
dashes out 43 moves in one minute why
not I mean he could have put me away
probably a number of times and he had
some black is just clearly better check
the night air force coming with this is
under the rook yeah stranger strange
game and I had one cough this problem
was that I got into a line that I don't
really know I wanted to to get into the
this philidor setup maybe c5 was a was
not really a good idea and well not
objectively speaking we transpose into
the closest ilion but i have no
experience whatsoever with setups with a
knight on f6 I always played the close
with the night only seven and the sir
really was a problem here in this game I
should probably play you five or
something getting into position types
that are no better the way it turned out
he got a very nice position somehow I I
lost lost lost I lost lots of time hmm
okay yeah well thanks for watching